Let’s talk about the protests in Lebanon.
People have been demonstrating for months
saying they’re tired of corruption
and a never-ending economic crisis.
For the stop of crushing liberties, freedoms
and to stop the economic nightmare in which we are.
In response Prime Minister Saad Hariri resigned
and now Lebanon has a new government.
But protesters are still on the streets.
They say their message is clear: we haven’t given up
and we aren’t going away.
So why don’t they support the new government?
And what is the back story for what’s going on in Lebanon?
Call it an anti-government movement
uprising or even a revolution.
What’s going on in Lebanon is something
many people there say they haven’t seen before.
This is a country with 18 officially recognised
religious groups, where people have traditionally supported
the interests of their own faith or sect.
But this is a new generation.
People from across the country took to the streets.
The sectarian divide was no longer there.
There was no class divide. It was the poor.
It was the middle class. It was the rich.
People who were just fed up.
Protesters say they’re fed up with a lot of things:
the economy, high taxes, lack of jobs
crumbling infrastructure and they say the biggest problem
is rampant corruption which has thrived
under Lebanon’s sectarian political system.
We’re going to explain that system in a second
but let’s get a sense of just how tough
everyday life is for most Lebanese people.
We don't really have access to proper public services.
Like there's no 24/7 electricity
there is no clean, accessible drinking water.
You have piles of garbage all over the country.
Sewage is not treated. It goes straight out to the ocean.
So it feels like the state is absent
from daily life in Lebanon.
Most people agree that mess is caused by
serious mismanagement.
Some say it’s because of corruption.
But you’ll also hear analysts say that Lebanon never
really recovered from a long and devastating war.
We’re talking about Lebanon’s civil war
which started in 1975 and went on for 15 years.
Militias from different sects and political groups
fought each other for dominance
and also fought among themselves.
Then Syria and Israel got involved
and the battles became even more destructive.
At the end of the war Lebanon’s main political
groups signed the Taif Agreement
to make sure they all got a slice of political power.
And that’s really the basis for Lebanon’s
political system today.
A Maronite Christian gets the presidency
the prime minister has to be Sunni Muslim
and the speaker of parliament is always a Shia Muslim.
In parliament seats are shared 50/50
between Muslims and Christians.
But in reality there are two big political alliances
which include parties from different sects
and they each have rival foreign powers backing them.
March 14 was former prime minister Saad Hariri’s bloc
which has the support of Saudi Arabia and the US.
March 8 is the bloc that includes the Maronite
Christian President Michel Aoun’s party and Hezbollah.
It has Syria and Iran’s support.
So because of all those overlapping
and competing interests many people will tell you that
Lebanon’s sectarian political system isn’t really sectarian.
What's really happening in Lebanon is that
there are political parties that used to be militias.
Sects are not fighting in Lebanon.
It's really opposing warlords backed by
opposing foreign powers.
And this is how, many say, corruption
has gotten so out of hand.
Many of those powerful political leaders
or the Zuama as they’re called in Lebanon
are said to have focused on their own political
and financial gains and made themselves very rich.
Lebanon has 220 km of coast.
180 km of the coast has been privatised.
It's now under the control of either former officials
and people who are close to them.
I'll just give you one example. Parking meters in Beirut.
The revenues were not going to the state.
They were going to a private company controlled
owned by people who are close to politicians.
Now that’s not to say that everyone in Lebanon
wants to overhaul the entire system.
The majority still support the mainly sectarian
political parties for a number of reasons.
One, ideological. Two, they benefit from those in power.
We're talking about at least 400,000 people
employed by the public sector. Now with their families
could you imagine that number?
Lebanon’s elite has responded to calls for a clean-up.
In 2019 Prime Minister Saad Hariri stepped down
and after months of talks the new prime minister
Hassan Diab, who’s a computer engineering
professor, finally announced his new government.
According to Diab it’s made up of technocrats
with no political loyalties
and it even has a record number of female ministers.
But not everyone is convinced this is real change.
The protesters had demanded a completely independent
technocratic government which just means
they’re politically independent and also
that they are experts in their fields.
It's kind of just the same thing. Like different faces
but same parties, same alliances.
Critics of the new government are saying that
many of those technocrats have the support
of the March 8 alliance, the one that includes Hezbollah.
And that complicates things.
Hezbollah is a Shia Muslim political group
and arguably Lebanon’s most powerful player.
It has a military wing the size of a small army funded by Iran.
Hezbollah is considered a
terrorist organisation by the US.
And the EU has blacklisted its armed wing.
Even just the perception of Hezbollah pulling the strings
might make it hard for Lebanon’s new government
to get the international funding it desperately needs.
This is a country with the world’s third highest level of
debt when you compare it to its small economy.
Its debt is more than $80 billion.
Lebanon’s former finance minister recently told Reuters
news agency that the country will need at least
a $20 billion bailout, possibly from the IMF
World Bank and Gulf countries.
In 2018 international donors agreed to give Lebanon
$11 billion in loans, grants and donations
but Lebanon hasn’t seen that money yet.
The message that Beirut is getting is enough is enough
you need to undertake painful but necessary reforms
in order for this funding to be released.
People in Lebanon are already feeling
the crisis getting worse.
Since protests began the value of Lebanon’s currency
has fallen by 60% and banks are already
limiting cash withdrawals to about $200 a week.
Violence is also escalating as police try to contain the rage.
So there’s defiance and some hope among protesters
that their campaign will lead somewhere.
But other Lebanese people we spoke to
say there’s still a very long road ahead.
One of our Lebanese colleagues despaired
that war-torn Syria might be back on its feet
before things get better in Lebanon.